hello everyone and welcome to the finals
of the American Cup it is eight-time U.S
women's champion Irina Crush Grand
Master Arena Crush versus feeding Master
uh Alice Lee only 13 years old but uh
crushing everyone she defeated a Nazi
pakiji International Master Nazi pakita
in the uh in in the semi-finals and now
she has black against Irina and I
thought about showing you a first uh uh
Alice's game from the semifinals but
when I saw a certain line in this game I
decided to show you this one first okay
even though that one happened prior to
this one uh first we're gonna show this
one and then that one so let's check it
out uh you guys uh we will not believe
this line uh let's let's see what I mean
by this so here we have C4 vairina going
after going for the English opening we
have Pawn to C6 now comes Ponte e for
and the D5 this is a very nice counter
to the pan of attack he captures with C
captures C captures and now Knight to F6
ready to recapture with the Knight
Knight the C3 but now Pawn to G6 not
going for the Knight right away with
Bishop to C4 now defending the pawn and
Bishop to G7 so Alice decided to at uh
again with the pawn and she will uh try
to regain it uh later on in the game
either by winning material or by uh
winning uh position wise so here Knight
gte2 we have Castles by both of them uh
and now Knight B to D7 we have Pawn to
D3 Ponta A6 and now Pawn to A4 stopping
B5 and here B6 and there are a couple of
games that reach this position Rook D1
is a known uh nice to a four is a known
move but here we have Pawn to H3 and it
is now as of move 11 that we have a
completely new game so Bishop to B7 of
course the bishop looks um uh very nice
on this long diagonal we have faunted D4
and now only Now Pawn to B5 uh what's
the idea behind this move uh a captures
on B5 seems like it's just giving up a
pawn now Knights the B6 first putting
pressure on the bishop and C4 Bishop
back to D3
uh not willing to part with the bishop
pair uh a captures and B5 Rook captures
an A8 with Queen capture 78 and now
Bishop captures on B5 and we're only 16
and moves in and if you count to the
pawns itina has six points and Alice
Alice has only four pawns uh but the B
Pawn okay it's uh it's a pass Pawn but
there are too many pieces on the board
to be considering that now uh and the
d-pawn is double so you're probably
gonna win one of them back uh uh but
still a very nicely done sacrificing
some material for activity Knight F
captures on D5 we have Knight captures
on D5 Bishop captures on D5 and now
Knight to F4 putting pressure on the
bishop and Bishop goes back to B7 and
now if you assess this position uh it's
uh it's a very tricky position because
white is up a pawn it's a past B Pawn
okay so white will uh try to to put
pressure on the queen side maybe even
Trace some pieces and then try to
advance that pawn all the way up the
board to become a queen and Alice will
of course try to use lies her Heavy
Artillery here to go after the white
king and here we have rooked the E1 and
this is the position that impressed me
the most when I was enjoying the game
because we have to ask the silly
question uh Queen and Bishop are aiming
at that G2 pawn and the only one
defending is the Knight on F4 so can we
play G5 or not that is the that is the
question here and the answer is that uh
no you can't but you have to be able to
see to like 20 moves into the future and
I don't think it's possible for anyone
to calculate this so I'm just going to
show it to you because it's absolutely
incredible if Ponta G5 this is why it's
impossible You're Gonna Play Knights to
H5 now comes Bishop captures on G2 and
okay it already looks like we're gonna
Checkmate the white king the problem is
there's Queen to D3 and now when we
threaten checkmate with Bishop to H1 now
comes Queen to G3 okay we stopped
Checkmate but now Bishop cappers on D4
uh King to H do not threatening to win
the up here so Bishop has to go back and
now Bishop captures on G5 threatening
some very nasty Discovery so you're
gonna move the king of course King to h8
now Bishop captures an E7 and now Rook
to G8 and again it seems like black is
completely dominating this position so
what's the problem here there's only one
move that wins the game for white and
it's uh it's a crazy one so feel free to
pause the video and try to solve this
hypothetical position uh while I give
you a couple of seconds
foreign
moves ahead and for those of you who
just want to enjoy the show uh the only
movie that wins is Bishop to G5 but it
it wins in so many fun ways that I am
just going to show you a few uh now we
have to ask ourselves uh why why what's
wrong with H6 what's wrong with F6
what's wrong with any of the moves
because this it doesn't seem like white
should be able to hold this the problem
with H6 attacking the bishop is that
there's this nice Queen to D6 idea and
now how do you stop Queen captures on H6
mate in one uh you have to play
something like Queen to B8 okay now you
stop uh Queen captures on H6 because the
queen uh the trade is being forced but
white will just trade captures captures
and now you're gonna play real captures
on e4 and if you count the pieces you
are up a full a full piece you're up
upper light score Bishop uh and also the
bishop and D4 is currently attacked and
if you capture on B2 then of course you
will capture on H6 and you're still
gonna be up a light Square Bishop so
that's why after this bishop to G5 move
H6 doesn't work but what about Ponte F6
now Queen to D6 makes no sense as spawn
to F6 I mean it makes no sense now the
problem is Knight captures an F6 and
again it looks like it shouldn't be
possible but it is what you play here
the bishop is now hanging the rook and
G8 is attacked how are you how are you
to survive this if you play something
like Rook cap or sun G8 Queen captures
on G8 now Bishop to G6 okay you're not
getting checkmated or anything but now
look at this Rook to E8 with check
absolutely spectacular uh Bishop
captures is of course impossible because
now the queen to G8 will be Checkmate
and if Queen characters then you just
part with your queen let's say Bishop
characters and that's pretty much it of
where you still can't capture because of
Checkmate uh this is just a straight
straight are winning black will get
checkmated in a couple of moves so after
Bishop to G5 you don't have H6 you don't
have F6 so what's the only other move
you have well that's the tricky one and
that's the one one that you really had
to calculate if you actually were
considering a pawn to G5 and that is
Pawn to F5 and now again it looks like a
white is the one to be in trouble here
but uh Rook to D1 you go after the
bishop Bishop captures on B2 and now you
play Knight to F6 attack the rook and
again it's the same idea if the bishop
captures them Bishop captures with check
this will be winning for white but what
about Rook to G7 just getting the Rook
out of a Harm's Way now comes Ponte F4
you don't have to worry about the bishop
anymore and uh H6 uh isn't all that
impressive because Queen to F2 will
threaten the bishop and B2 and you don't
want to allow that so here you will play
uh after this bishop to G5 move you have
to play Bishop to D4 and unless you want
to allow the bishop to remain on such a
beautiful diagonal you have to play Rook
captures on D4 and now comes Queen to A2
with check you can't go anywhere on G2
or H1 so you have to play you can play
King to G1 if King to G1 then just Queen
to A1 check picks up the rook and D4 so
you're gonna have to play Bishop to E2
and give up the bishop Queen captures on
E2 and only now King to G1 and now uh
okay we've traded down a little bit but
basically what you will get is Knights
to D5 Knight captures on D5 and now this
uh Queen to A6 move I mean absolutely
absolutely beautiful now you don't have
to worry about Bishop to F6 because
Queen just captures the bishop uh and
then after Knight captures you lose the
queen with check and also you are
threatening Queen A1 check once again to
win that rook and D4 and now after Rook
captures on e4 F captures an E4 You're
Gonna Play Queen to G2 and now after
Pawn to E3 as you are preparing to bring
that pawn all the way to E2 you're gonna
capture Knight captures now comes spawn
to H6 winning back the bishop Knight F5
uh Queen to B6 with check King to H2 and
now age captures on G5 Knight captures
on G7 King captures on G7 and queen
captures on G5 with check and now we
would end this line with white being up
two Pawns in a in a of course a winning
position so if you actually wanted to
try
um uh if you actually wanted to try G5
here you would have to calculate all of
this and you would figure out that in
the end the white will just be up two
points in a queen Pawn end game so
that's why she did not play G5 she
played Ponte E6 so you don't have to
worry about your E7 Pawn but I mean
quite a line so here we have Bishop back
to F1 now the G2 Pawn is defended and
you don't have to worry now the Knight
can move
uh Rook the d8 nicely aligning The Rook
with the queen also the D4 Pawn is now
hanging and you're gonna have to give it
up Queen to B3 uh we have Bishop
captures on D4 now the bishop pair is
most certainly fully operational Bishop
to E3 she has to take care of one of The
Bishop's Bishop captures we have Queen
captures and E3 and now Knight to D5 you
can't just leave the Knight there
because then maybe some Knight captures
on E6 is an option okay probably not
because if you captured in Rook d8 but
you don't wanna even have this as an
option and also the Knight is just
hanging there so Knight to D5 uh here
there was a trade Knight captures Rook
captures and now again material is uh
completely equal uh Irina has a passport
on on B2 so she advances it all the way
to B4 as one always should uh Bishop to
C6 we have G3 now so you don't have to
worry about the G2 Pawn ever again and
now Rook to D7 we have Pawn to B5 in the
past Pawn marches forward Bishop to B7
and now Queen to E5 with Queen to A3 and
now uh well there are a couple of
options you could explore but basically
everything you do will end up in a
three-fold repetition if you try to do
some sort of a rook lift then Queen the
C1 is annoying now your Bishop cannot
move we will probably someday grew back
to E1 Queen back to A3 so in the in the
actual game Queen the B8 check was
played King to G7 and now a nice
repetition Queen to E5 checking the G8
Queen to B8 with check King to G7 and
now Queen to E5 with check and it was in
this position unmove 32 that arena in
Dallas agreed to a draw as there is
nothing more to be done here so truly
truly a remarkable game uh from uh from
the first round of the finals and you
can see just uh how much pressure
um uh Alice is putting on on her
opponents regardless of whether she
plays white or black uh it's absolutely
incredible and Irina even said uh after
the game in her commentary that the if
Alice really wants that uh she's uh she
has no doubt that she she will become a
grand master so we'll see what happens
in game two where Alice will have the
white pieces will we have another
attacking game or maybe something else
uh stay tuned for that but yeah I will
show the the game between Alice and Nazi
next so stay tuned for that and if you
guys are wondering what happened in the
uh men's section of the American Cup it
was uh it was pretty much a snoozefest
of a very quick draw between between
Hikaru and Wesley uh so yeah that's the
game hope you guys enjoyed it I would
like to thank Mike Wagner uh thought
dreams um very nice video yesterday Ryan
Kavanaugh and Henry Spraggins for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check to my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon continuing to check up on you
wonderful suggestions and whatever else
happens in the Chess World thank you all
I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day